what's your favorite part about Canada
well I'm not necessarily what my
favorite part of Canada is because
no no but we're going to manifest that
um I love Toronto
it's a beautiful city that's really the
only place I've really been
um but I loved it there because it was
like the city but then not
you know it's like this growing city but
it's so beautiful and the people are so
nice like they say hello to you on the
street yeah it's almost like a southern
city it is a bit yes very like sweet and
you're like did they just say hello to
me
um and I don't know you know I took my
store there
in December and we got great response so
that was cool
um and the fashion there is amazing like
it's really good shot it's good shopping
in Toronto and the restaurants too like
it was I had a blast there awesome the
dating is not great in Toronto I will
say so we're not going to look for a man
in Toronto
um this group is a tough Group Beverly
Hills what's been the most challenging
part but uh word on the street is it can
be a challenging group what's the
toughest part about coming into this
group specifically well I think for for
myself it was challenging because they
all knew each other and they were really
tight and
um okay so they were sort of like what's
she doing here
and so you have to like really get in
and so that was kind of the hardest part
for me just kind of breaking into the
group right and like the longer you've
been on the show we can really see you
owning your voice and you know standing
with conviction which has been amazing
what scene are you most proud of from
this season
um
gosh what's saying you know I think my
papa's scene with Erica I was really
proud of that and and of her because we
had a very adult calm conversation and I
thought that you got to see both of us
use our words and come to an
understanding and I I loved it I in fact
I texted her when we got that episode
and I said I really loved that scene
between us and she said it was really
great so yeah I thought it was a great I
mean one of my favorites I agree I agree
thank you so much